up next we have dr. ksenia yeshivah she
is the deputy science scientific
director for the Center for suicide risk
assessment and is based in new york
state psychiatric institute in the
Columbia University Medical School she
works in outpatient inpatient emergency
services and conducts field assessments
for state international programs and
it's been very involved with leading the
psychometric validation work for the
Columbia suicide severity rating scale
so I think that you will find what she's
going to talk about with regards to
assessment really relevant in many
applications today so join me in
welcoming dr. Shova I just said I should
start by reference to guess where my
first connection to the topic came from
I was sitting in reminiscing and
realized that when I started training
and trained clinical psychologist my
first three adult patients is it a boy
too quiet oh can we turn up the volume
hold on second okay so um okay so the
first three patients um obviously didn't
know what I was doing just started and
all three patients the first one was a
woman with chronic skin condition and
chronic self-injurious behavior and what
I learned by working with this patient
and two others was that personality
organization really matters and this
first patient was in fact
a patient with a birth borderline
personality disorder and I have to say
that what besides just this was a very
humbling experience to start with
patient or the borderline personality
disorder narcissistic personality
disorder I'm schizoid personality
disorder as a first-year student i can
say that what really helped me
understand and begin to learn how to be
with patients and relate and hopefully
do clinical work is sitting with a
supervisor who was a very close
unfortunately he's no longer with us a
very close colleague of the developers
of mental ization based approach to
treatment of borderline personality
disorder who developed an instrument for
looking at psychotherapy process and
that instrument what was particularly
remarkable about it is that it was pen
theoretical what I mean by that is that
you could apply that instrument in when
you're looking at psychotherapy process
whether it's CBT dbt ipt psychoanalysis
it didn't matter it translated all of
our interventions into common language
and consistently applying and looking at
clinical material with that pan
theoretical method that gave common
language was incredibly important in
seeing patterns and arriving at real
understanding and I give you this frame
because ultimately what I'm going to
talk about today is an instrument it's
one method of assessing identifying
detecting suicidal ideation and behavior
and what I'd like to do is to make it to
make this talk very hands-on okay and
apply it to many contacts so I will echo
some of the things that nicole has
already covered but mostly focused on
that on the instrument and the method so
this is at this point I think this has
become a common refrain that fifty
percent of people see the primary care
provider people who die by suicide in
there in a month before they die and
twenty-five of people who die by suicide
are seen in the emergency room in the
past 12 months for non psychiatric
reasons and many attempters in the
emergency rooms are including
adolescents are there for not
psychiatric reasons so as nicole has
already addressed this rising mortality
and morbidity associated with suicide
across many groups and very significant
rise in suicide rates in the last decade
and some of you may be familiar with a
study that was published in the last
year that really really before the last
CDC report that just came out was a
serious kind of light bulb moment in for
those of us in suicide research that
looked or found that particularly in the
white non-hispanic men and women of
middle age the rising mortality was
just unprecedented and the three main
causes were poisoning substance
poisoning suicides and liver disease
this is United States this is in
contrast to what was happening before
and this is in contrast to what's
happening in other countries so this is
us oops sorry oops oops oops this so
this is us right and this is all of not
all but some of the other European
countries and this is what's happening
to mortality rates there so this is from
the most recent CDC report and Nicole
already mentioned this the dramatic
increase in women in suicide rates and
women girls and I don't really need to
cover this but mental illness is a very
prominent factor and ninety percent of
people who die by suicide have mental
illness and many many and this has been
highlighted this morning do not receive
the treatment that they need okay where
am I going with this all of this what I
think this tells us is that suicide risk
even though it is typically or
historically has been perceived as a
psychiatric issue really cuts across
affects people across medical conditions
settings and demographic groups and the
entry point for asking about suicide
suicidal thoughts and behaviors is way
way way upstream from psychiatry so and
connecting this to my I guess overall
underlying
of developing a common language this is
not my message this is a World Health
Organization this is data from the
programs that are actually successful in
preventing suicide coming together
across sectors is incredibly important
in understanding how we talk about risk
giving vocabulary is incredibly
incredibly important so these are just I
outlined some basic domains of clinical
suicide risk assessment towards forget
clinical still as you said risk
assessment and really just to point out
where my talk is going to focus on we
can't really expect anyone to ask about
suicide whether it's nurse whether it's
a police officer whether it's a
psychiatrist whether it's a nurse unless
there's a belief that you can prevent
you can prevent suicide and so the
question is it suicide preventable can I
ask those are some of the questions that
that that we have to answer in the
affirmative and accurate risk assessment
is the domain where I am really going to
spend most of my time what do we ask and
how do we ask and how do we put suicide
risk into language that all of us
understand okay so let's just look
quickly at some of the common beliefs
that when we talk when we do some sort
of program evaluation we actually asked
about people's beliefs and then look at
attitude change and then look
at what changes as far as how
consistently different settings begin to
ask about suicide so these are some of
the thoughts that and attitudes that
come up over and over again there's no
point in asking about suicide because if
someone's going to attempt suicide they
will not tell you the reality is that
manual when you ask directly and
ambiguously and you know eighty percent
of people who die by suicide give some
indication of warning and the the state
of human condition is ambivalence no one
is dead sure pun intended to that they
really want to die okay very very few
people actually have that kind of a
hundred percent confidence asking a
depressed person about suicide may give
them an idea about doing it so asking
does not asking does not suggest suicide
or make it more likely we do have to
worry about such as suggestibility
contagion but this is no not where we
worried how media covers suicide is
where we worry about suggestibility and
contagion but asking directly about have
you attempted are you thinking about X
does not produce suicidal thoughts and
make somebody more suicidal so if you
stop someone from killing themselves one
way they'll probably find another way to
do it so means restriction although I
have to this is a side note in our work
with the military we found out that this
is not a favorable expression and as
soon as you start talking that means
extra restriction you really lose most
of the audience when you were talking to
military and
so the idea really is that interventions
or suicide risk prevention programs
target lethal methods and that really
has strong evidence of efficacy so here
just a couple of examples England
changed from bottles to blistering
packages of Tylenol and they saw forty
four percent reduction in tylenol
overdose in eleven year so just by
restricting restricting the ability to
do this with the pills and and extending
the time that it takes to pop those
pills out you produce an important
effect protective effect Israeli
military 2006 restricted gun access on
weekends look what happened drop the
suicide rate drop by forty percent okay
if someone is really suicidal they are
probably going to kill themselves at
some point no matter what you do most
people are suicidal only for a short
period of time this is why I just
emphasize tylenol example time is is a
factor many suicide attempters do not go
on to die by suicide so what do what do
we ask how do we ask this study shows
how important one word can be in
changing prevalence rates or our
estimates of how frequently suicide
happens so in Ron Keslar study the
reanalysis of the national comorbidity
survey once they started requiring
intent to die in the definition of
suicidal attempt the lifetime prevalence
in the United States their estimates of
self-reported suicide attempts dropped
from almost almost
five percent to 2.7 so this is getting
at the distinction between different
forms of self-injurious behavior but the
point is that definitions have a serious
effect so I'm going to tell you a little
bit about where this instrument is
coming came from because the story is
the story is telling pun intended again
so so a decade ago there was a group of
researchers some of them are in the
audience who were working on the first
really amazing study of treatment for
adolescent suicide attempters at the
same time those of you who remember
there was the black box controversial
what became a black box surrounding the
issue of antidepressant potentially
increasing suicidal ideation in
adolescence FDA when they looked at all
the adverse event data they became
worried because they realized that there
was no consistency in how these
potentially suicidal events were labeled
so they came to Columbia they came to
this group of researchers and that
really gave birth to the system that I'm
a method that I'm going to be describing
so when the team looked at all the
adverse event explanation of in Sri
descriptions there were you know 38
discrepant ratings what would you guess
was the category with the least
agreement
specifically on suicide attempt what
does it tell us we can't agree on one
category that we think we all know what
it is so and then the consequence of
this reclassification was against
something similar to what I just told
you about Ron Kessler's a reanalysis
that the rates of suicide attempts were
lower okay these are just some examples
and I think they really drive the point
some of the points home on the left you
see the original labels for the clinical
descriptions of events okay so let's
just look the patient took 11 tablets
impulsively and then went to school the
patient denied that it was a suicide
attempt medication error after arguing
with his stepfather ten-year-old boy
wrapped a cord from the mini blinds
around his neck threatening to kill
himself hostility that was the label
that was given hitting his head on the
wall the patient explained it is like my
thoughts are about to explode that was
labeled a suicide attempt so what would
it take for this event to be labeled
medication air this boy took it by
mistake whose medication air and what
would it take how would one arrive at a
label like this my explanation is that
the subjective feelings of the raider
arrived at this label the Raider
probably thought oh this was
manipulative this was intentional
behavior towards the parent so the point
of the instrument ultimately is to take
that out that subjective feeling about
what is really
opening okay and stick with the
descriptions so and if you notice the
Miss classification of Miss descriptions
happened in both directions so it's not
like there was some sort of an
intentional decision on the part of the
reader to under rate or override ok so
the the instrument Columbia said
severity rating scale was developed as i
said in the nih trial of treatment for
adolescent suicide attempters and the
specific focus really was on measuring
ideation behavior separately have both
categorical and dimensional indicators
of ideation and behavior such that you
would actually be able to track change
over time so I'm going to skip the
description elvia study except to say
that this is an adolescent sample and in
a nutshell this is the scale there are
four parts there the to this to this
method ideation suicidal ideation
suicidal behavior and dimensional
indicators of both so suicidal ideation
we have five different types of thoughts
types yes now and then five dimensional
characteristics of the most severe
thought and suicidal behavior similarly
we have five types of behavior that
we're looking at or looking whether it's
there and then there's a dimensional
indicator of how severe how
rather the attempt in particular was so
and I want to highlight the structure
because I think that's one of the real
strengths of this particular method and
then as I'm saying this is one method
for doing suicide risk assessment but
the undeniable strength I think of this
method is that you have the term you
have the definition and you have the
suggested questions in order for us to
speak the same language we have to
understand that we are meet while we
mean the same thing okay so let's just
look more in more detail or what or what
these four sections or of the over the
method look like so just to highlight
five types of ideation from which to be
dead to nonspecific thoughts of killing
oneself and then what would be called
active ideation with method than with
intent and I will go over these in just
more detail in just a minute okay so you
know what I realized that I didn't turn
my timer on so how am i doing on time
okay all right great thank you so um
okay so what you're looking at right now
is the suicidal ideation section that
asks about five types of thoughts the
first two questions are really the
screening questions and you first asked
whether a person wishes to be dead and
then you asked about whether they're
have any thoughts of killing themselves
and if the answer is yes to the question
about killing wanting to kill oneself
then you ask about the type of active
thought that they're actually having do
they have a method in
find do they have a specific plan and
we'll look at these in more detail so
have you wished you were dead or wished
you could go to sleep and not wake up
have you actually had any thoughts of
killing oneself third type of thought
have you been thinking about how you
might do this so let's pause and think
what is the difference between what is
the transition from 12 to the transition
from one to two is one is wishing to be
dead 21 thinking about becoming an agent
of caring that desire out that's the
transition from what historically was
called passive ideation to activation so
you are thinking about becoming an agent
and the this is the subsequent three
types of active ideations thoughts one
the first one is method the next one do
you have any intent intention to act on
these thoughts that you're having of
killing yourself and then the most
severe level would be have you started
to work out a plan for killing yourself
where you have your pretty specific
about time and place and confident
reasonably confident or forget the
reasonably confident confident and that
you have intent some intent on acting on
these thoughts so let's just look at an
example the patient thought about dying
and how easy it would be to pretend to
fall in front of a bus before before so
that the death would look like an
accident although he thought about often
he said he did not have the courage to
do it
what do we think this is all right so
with the kids and some of this really
applies not just the kids the very
important thing for all of us and again
this is the the message about trying to
leave your subjective thoughts about
what this might be outside you have to
figure out what we have to ask what the
person you're interviewing it is
believed about what was going to happen
so the example that I usually give is
that one of my little kids I talked to
believed on the inpatient unit believe
that she could cut off her circulation
with a bunch of rubber bands most of us
who think you know not a big deal like
you know you can't really die by
wrapping some rubber bands around your
wrist but the point here is not to judge
the lethality the point is to figure out
what the intent was so when that girl
tells me yes I wanted to die that's what
matters in terms of figuring out what
the meaning of the behavior was okay the
intensity of thoughts this is when we
figure out what types of thought the
person is having and then we try and
characterize it in terms of its
intensity and these are some of them not
some of these are the parameters the
frequency duration controllability
deterrence and you know reasons for
feeling the way that they're feeling or
having these thoughts so this is how the
intensity of ideation looks you have in
this slide as well and I'll just walk
you quickly through how you would go
about
asking these questions so let's just say
you asked the person and they said yes
to wish to die yes the yes I've been
thinking or I've thought about killing
myself and then you proceed to the last
three questions and the purse oops sorry
the person says yes I've been thinking
about how am I do this let's just say
pills and then when you ask the
subsequent questions the answers are
known so what happens with intensity is
that you take the most severe thought in
this case in this person's case I just
say they were thinking about killing
themselves by ingesting pills that means
the most severe type is three and then
you start asking questions about well
how frequently have you been thinking
about us how long do these last these
thoughts last and so you go through
these five questions and obtain a total
score and do we have a cut-off for
what's bad what's super bad what's sort
of bad no it really it really varies by
clinical population if you're working
with suicide attempters the meaning of
these numbers will change the general of
course interpretation is that the higher
the total score the worst the worst the
person is so you know the in some
assessments we don't look at intensity
but the evidence that is accumulating is
that intensity might actually be a
stronger predictor of suicidal behavior
for certain groups so we've definitely
seen that without
sense I mean this is a study from
inpatient unit by one of the colleagues
at the University of Michigan but this
is not just the only group that that is
finding finding this Anthony speedos
group recently came out with a
publication also suggesting that
suicidal ideation in adolescence
particularly might have more dimensional
quality than in adults so you call
already suggested that it is important
to know and differentiate suicidal
versus non-suicidal so in the suicidal
behavior we first asked about actual
attempt have you made a serious attempt
have you done anything to harm yourself
so the the these are some suggested
questions that you could be asking and
I'll go over the other definitions in
just a second and then there's also
question and this is where you as an
interviewer you do have to make a
decision in distinction between whether
the self-injurious behavior is attempt
or self-injurious behavior with no
suicidal intent and I'll just walk you
through that in just a minute okay so
suicidal attempt so under this
conceptualization and you know there are
good reasons for defining suicide
attempt this way the definition is this
a potentially self-injurious act
committed with at least some intent to
die as a result of the act there are
some important changes in that
definition from the historical
definitions that we've had a suicide
attempt notice potential notice some
intent ok so the non zero intent to do
is probably the biggest
change in the sinking and we don't
necessarily all agree and they feel but
nonetheless there's plenty of evidence
to say that there is a good reason to
use a non-zero intent as a criterion so
even if you want even even if a small
small part of you in the back of your
mind did whatever you did with a little
bit of an intent we saw yeah maybe I
want to die for us that is suicidal
attempt okay and potential for injury
why why focus on potential is because
there are many instances when there is
no injury think of rubber bands did this
girl hurt herself not really was it a
suicide attempt yes and it's a real
change in thinking it's a real change in
and our description of what suicidal
ideation behavior would be and of course
the intent and behavior have to be
causally coherent they have to be linked
so you undertook a certain behavior
because at least part of you that or at
least a little bit of you wanted to to
die okay so just to highlight that you
know the this is not a total agreement
if you look at the American Psychiatric
Association current definition this is
how this is the definition
self-injurious behavior with non fatal
outcome accompanied by evidence implicit
or explicit that the person intended to
die so that if you ponder this this
definition points to a much stronger
evidence for suicidal intent than a
nonzero criterion that that I just gave
you so even though I said that
we try the one of the result death or
the one of the important reasons for
this method is to take subjective
subjectivity our radars our inclinations
our interviewers subjectivity out of
describing or deciding how to describe
there are two instances where if a
person denies intent that you can very
reasonably infer that the person was in
fact suicidal and particularly this one
I think well in practice I've certainly
used this question many times and have
been surprised at the change in the
rating just because of the answer now I
didn't want to die no no no no no no no
no I did not want to die what did you
think that if you took this many pills
or when you were collecting them did you
think that you could a good diaphragm it
if the answer is yes you can say that
they knew the possibility and that
really suggests that there was at least
part of them that was the head suicidal
intent okay and in certain cases and
this is less clear but in certain cases
the clinical circumstances are such that
there is no other intent that could be
conceived of by in a rational reason so
the example that comes up in in our
presentations often is you know soldier
denying suicidal attempt after shooting
himself in the head you know there are a
lot of consequences to admitting
negative consequences or perceive
negative consequences for soldiers for
example the military to admitting
suicidal behavior so this particular
was really batiment about not having not
having attempted okay so distinction
really ultimately comes down to non zero
vs 0 attempt I mean intent okay if the
behavior was undertaken purely for other
reasons it would be non-suicidal self
injurious behavior and in research I
have to say just fast forward a little
bit what even though in Europe there's a
tendency to merge the two in
surveillance work and research the the
non suicidal and suicidal injury what we
see in I think empirical literature on
treatment efficacy is that it's
important to delineate and differentiate
the two some interventions and maybe
some of you are familiar with the study
just came out a meta-analysis of
treatment studies of different types of
treatments for suicidal ideation
behavior there was a different pattern
depending on outcome you are looking at
for non-suicidal self-injury the
behavior most of these treatments didn't
do anything didn't work for suicidal
attempts there was efficacy ok so the
this differentiation does have an
important effect on how we construct and
conduct our treatments ok so the this is
this is just an illustration where we
get to that ok so the implications there
are several implications are already
started in practice clinicians tend to
underplay significance of
non-suicidal Santa jurors behavior and
and can often end up giving less a
thorough evaluation of these patients
and in many patients including patients
with borderline personality disorder
again recognizing heterogeneity within
the borderline personality disorder
diagnosis nonetheless non-suicidal
self-injury could be a more significant
predictor of suicidal attempt and
suicide death so and what we do know is
that when when non-suicidal self-injury
has internal motives when it's done in
isolation when it's more frequent with
more methods and when there's less pain
felt that those parameters of those
indicators allow you to conclude that
the person is a much higher risk from
engaging in non-suicidal self-injury
okay the patient cut her wrists after an
argument with her boyfriend suicide
attempt or no okay let's see if anything
changes for you
anything change for anybody no yes can I
have can I hear no yes all right ok so
again this is getting at the idea that
facility level of intervention does not
tell you whether suicidal ideas suicidal
behaviors suicidal ok a woman had a big
fight with her ex-husband took 20 pills
went to bed slept through the night 5
p.m. next day woke up stated couldn't
stand up a walk called EMS when to your
stomach was pumped unable to verbalize
clear intent but stated she was aware of
the dangers of overdose and the
potential for death all right ok so um
all right other behaviors and I'll tell
you I'll be the first to admit that I
was not trained to assess for this you
know went to pretty good graduate
program not trained and when I talk to
my friends and colleagues in psychiatry
many times I hear the same thing never
asked about whether somebody tried but
stop themselves ok so several behaviors
that are important their predictive of
suicidal behavior they're more frequent
than suicide attempts some of them like
self interrupted attempts in certain
cases may be even more dangerous than
history of attempts no sorry not self
interrupted interrupted by others so
when a person starts to take steps to
end his or her life but someone
something stops him has there been a
time when you started to do something to
end your life but someone or something
stopped you before you actually did
anything ok so self interrupted similar
idea but you stopped yourself ok and
again think back to the nutshell
slide term definition suggested question
suggested probe okay and then there are
a couple of examples that offer hear
that somebody driving and then stopping
changing your mind no no I'm not going
to i'm not going to actually go through
this okay and one important distinction
is that the harm or the potential for
harm and this is difficult cannot start
I'm sorry in order for behavior to not
be us to be termed interrupted or self
interrupted for example if somebody
takes one pill and changes their mind
you would still call it a suicidal
attempt because the potential for harm
has begun in interrupted or self
interrupted behaviors or preparatory
behaviors the harm has not started yet
okay that's also critical distinction
okay so preparatory behaviors again
something that never asked in my
training and and you'd be surprised now
never tempted no and never tried no
never really started and stopped well
have you collected pills have you just
in case you know have you written a
suicide note and you'd be surprised the
answer could be yes and unless you ask
specifically objectively was no with no
kind of presupposition based on absence
of suicidal attempt you might get to
that answer and we've certainly seen
cases like this where a person was
evaluated in the clinic no suicidal
behavior it turns out that he already
packed up all his clothes at home in
bags to be given away but no hasn't
started anything hasn't interrupted
himself and has not attempted anything
okay all right so the woman feels her
monthly prescription for an
antidepressant early she's saving her
extra medication for the future in case
she needs a way to weigh out yeah okay a
girl was in her room with a bottle of
her mother's sleeping meds in her hand
planning to take them in the hope of
dying the girl's mother came in and
stopped the girl before she ingested any
right okay so um the behavior
definitions are very similar now to CDC
CDC worked very closely with columbia
and the surveillance that it's happening
now suicidal behavior really refers to
the suicidal behavior definitions that I
just covered ok so this list of terms
that CDC really discourages from using
goes back to the point about objective
description okay we can agree disagree
whether there is a reason good reason to
use some of these but just to make the
point failed attempt we don't want
people to be successful okay this is not
a failure okay we don't and we don't
want success either okay and even though
you know I'm not going to go through all
of these but the main point is the one
that I just gave you and certainly
certainly this is pretty understandable
that you know calling a behavior hostile
is not the way to go about classifying
okay so lasala t the main point here is
that there's actual LaSala tea and
potential LaSala tea okay
an actual Ellis allottee really is how
how severe is the medical damage that
you can you can see tissue
hospitalization etc but what's
particularly important is that is to
look at potential reality again
rubberband example is one extreme of you
know potential lethality was probably
pretty low what no probably was very
long next to zero but what if somebody
was laying down on the tracks and for
whatever reason miscalculated the the
train schedule if that train came there
was no way that person was going to
survive so the potential LaSala t is was
lethal okay so comparing this method to
some others that are out there phq-9
great depression screener has one
question and in the screener is really
tied to the DSM criteria for depression
so one domain is suicidal ideation
behavior so this is the question
thoughts that you would be better off
dead or hurting yourself in some way now
that I've walked you through do you feel
like this is a sufficient question to
get at ideation and behavior okay so
based on what I just I think described
to you this question does miss most
types of suicidal ideation and behavior
and does not critically does not
differentiate between suicidal and non
suicidal behavior we can once again
argue whether better off dead is
suicidal sought or not suicidal sought
under this conceptualization it's a it's
not a suicidal thought but certainly is
a morbid thought but once again this is
we can
have that conversation for the sake of
time I'm not going to launch into it so
and some of the empirical studies that
we've looked at have shown just that
very dif that the rates that you can get
based on the one question a very
different compared to more delineated
way of looking at ideation behavior okay
so one example one example is 200
patients with depression that came
through our throughout through our
Hospital and look what happened so this
is CSRs and almost thirty percent of
patients with suicidal ideation were not
detected by regular clinical interview
right just open ended etc and almost
twenty percent with a history of an
attempt okay so this is a very recent
study by greg brown and barbara stanley
who's going to be speaking in just a
little bit but again a very poignant
result where even in the situation where
there was a pretty high agreement like
higher than you would normally expect
there was a discrepancy in the rate in
the ratings of suicidal attempts and a
regular clinical assessment okay what
I'd like to highlight I know this is
like almost broken record but oops sorry
what I would like to highlight is that
the cases that were missed by regular
clinical assessment had lower lethality
than cases with better agreement what
does it tell us we're still referring to
how badly did the person
it hurt as our criterion for defining
suicidal behavior ok it's a rubber band
example again right ok so with this
method it does become somewhat easier to
develop clinical guidelines even though
again when you're working with different
populations different groups the
thresholds the cut-offs are going to be
different but the general rule of thumb
is that once a person has active
suicidal ideation with any intent to act
on their plan they're in a different
category in terms of risk ok and I've
outlined some cave caveats i don't know
if i have time probably don't month okay
so i'm not going to go through the
different caveats because there's
statistical caveats to how you think
about risk but olin yeah so this is
basically the last slide so maybe i'll
tell you a little bit so the the
difficulty with instruments with methods
that look at suicidal ideation behavior
is that we're working with a very scary
phenomenon but a rarely occurring i mean
we don't feel like it's rarely occurring
but statistically speaking this is not
diabetes for example and statistically
what that translates to is that our
methods do not have a very high
probability of actually picking up the
the patients who will go on to attempt
and I know this is this doesn't sound
very encouraging but but there is a
statistical reality to to this work and
and the the importance of full risk
formulation and
and this is what I started with this is
risk assessment there's a difference
between a risk assessment and risk
formulation so for a full risk
formulation you're not just going to
look at ideation and behavior you're
going to look at a whole host of risk
factors and relevant to our conversation
today borderline personality disorder
once again like the study that I was
referring to in terms of efficacy of
different therapeutic approaches that
exists to suicidal ideation behavior one
moderator or one group for which
treatment worked was borderline
personality disorder patients that was
one of the moderators okay so this is
just an example of how some of these
guidelines get articulate or integrated
and some of the systems this is a you
know beta testing so to speak of New
York State electronic medical record
just to show you that for example for
Medicaid patients the state can mandate
how they're going to be assessed
speaking of like bringing healthcare
together in different sectors and so
they are looking at these particular
rules for deciding on the level of risk
so the point that I'm making is that
the risk will fluctuate the risk will
vary based on the clinical population or
non-symmetrical population that you're
working with and but this this
particular method helps you describe
more objectively the phenomena that
you're working with are you seeing what
you're encountering and it would
prepares you I think better prepares you
to move on to risk formulation okay all
right thank you so much